cnbc what appears to be some good news
russia repositions troops away from kiev
marking a shift in the war well this
sound this sounds good i mean the troops
are going to be moving away from kim it
sounds like vladimir putin is is gearing
up to to pull back maybe even retreat
and
retreat to a high uh retreat his high
command into nuclear nuclear bunkers
okay that being the case it now kind of
reframes the retreat into is vladimir
putin pulling his troops out of kiev
because he's going to drop a bombs on
kiev
is that a stretch
no clue absolutely no clue but i agree
with you that it definitely changes the
tone of the story to hear that he was
going into a nuclear bunker rather than
just pulling out
i do have to wonder though if this is
just tabloid click bait yeah yeah i mean
after what i've been through the last
couple years i don't believe much of
what the media says so it's uh
i think it could be if he's in hiding it
could be because they've got inside
information that maybe his own people
are going to take him out because
they're tired of losing family and
friends in this useless war but is even
that true yeah who knows this is the
crazy thing about the about the war is
that
for obvious reasons you have all of
these outlets reporting
that you know putin's fled to a bunker
they're citing this journal journalist
christo grossov who has links to british
investigative outlet bellingcat
but it's too juicy a story for any of
these outlets to pass up right they
absolutely have to and
you know my issue with how all of these
articles frame is look i think we should
talk about it i think if there's a
possibility an investigative reporter is
saying hey this may be the case it's
probably a good thing people know
because while we're probably not going
to see nukes dropped anywhere
you just you know you don't want to
imagine imagine you do get someone who's
ready to fire nukes and some story
happens that indicates it might happen
and they don't tell you you know you we
you better know but uh i'd i'd
appreciate if these out these articles
would start by saying
it's a single investigative journalist
looking at flight paths from government
you know planes well when was this put
out
it starts today and it's uh about metro
there's oh no it's everything i mean
everyone's picked it up okay so so
they're all citing this one guy from
belgium he's going to say if nobody else
is talking about then it's probably true
yeah all right
you know they don't they were scared
about it yeah yeah i wonder if uh you
know we've seen all this media saying
putin's losing
they're like he's retreating he's losing
it's not going well we constantly hear
these stories about how his generals are
dying and i just don't know whether to
believe any of it no i mean so i was
talking about this with alex on the
green room
or in the green room
yesterday and people have been talking a
lot about russian disinformation we
shouldn't believe anything we hear about
the war that comes from the russian
government and fair enough i have no
reason to trust them but also i have
reasons to actively distrust my own
government and the uh industrial you
know military media complex that our own
country has and so we're almost in the
dark who is it i think it was mark twain
who said it's better to be uh uninformed
than misinformed something along those
lines it's just every single time cons i
consume news media i almost feel like
i'm getting dumber yeah so i i do want
to make sure you point out oh we have
the story from times of israel zielinski
says he's willing to make concessions to
achieve peace without delay which
includes a compromise on the donbass
region so this is yesterday it's
entirely possible what's really
happening is
vladimir putin's already been in a
secure location they're pulling the
troops back because they've won
is this this is what vladimir putin
wanted the eastern region of ukraine so
no nuclear war what do we do afterwards
do we do we just say okay putin's label
to keep taking these territories and
just oh i hear you i mean i'll i'll
borrow a point from you here tim
and paraphrase you a bit uh i am not
going to get my foreign policy wisdom
from the people who believe jesse
smallette
then who do you believe man yeah the
people who believe the covington kids
yeah
i'm sorry who did not believe the
covington kids got that one wrong who's
gotten every single story wrong who are
you supposed to believe when we're
talking about war yeah i think i think
social media has become i mean this is
the first we're fighting with active
live social media stuff so we're getting
a totally different take
and a different spin than we're used to
and so i think maybe
some of the things are going to be good
kind of like during the protests in 2020
we had the live streamers out there and
if we didn't have them we wouldn't have
really known what was going on because
the stuff you got were mostly peaceful
you know where the hou while the fire's
burning the building behind them and i
think that's prob hopefully that's going
to be the same thing that happens here
we'll get some on the ground legit
people that are part of it that can
actually give us some of the truth yeah
i mean
it sounds a little bit cheesy right
because we hear people in the media
using this as a talking point all the
time but it is really important for
people to be able to trust their media
unfortunately we're really not able to
there's just no media apparatus we can
count on to reliably tell us the truth
and so they're constantly bellowing
about the fact that no one trusts them
and they're constantly saying if we
really want to have a functioning
society there needs to be some common
narrative people unite on and no one
believes us but then they never take
responsibility for lying and it's kind
of funny it would almost be as if you
were constantly cheating on your wife
and when she didn't trust you when you
you know told her you were just at work
late your response was you know a
household can't function if you don't
trust your spouse okay well there's a
reason it's true we do need to be able
to have people in these positions who we
can trust but we're just not able to and
i think we've gotten so cynical on media
over the past couple years and i've
basically been cynical on media my
entire life that you you lose sight of
the fact that we've
it's really very sad that there aren't
people we can like genuinely count on to
give us the truth here i don't know if
there ever was truth
well i would agree with and that's the
thing i i i would also agree that
oftentimes we we have a lot we have our
nostalgia goggles on right and we look
at the past and say that that's when the
media was honest but we know that isn't
true like the new york times covered up
the hall of the more there's there's a
lot to dig into with the fact that our
media was basically always dishonest and
so i'm glad that's being exposed
i really am but it just makes you sad
that people don't have sources they can
trust and i think part of it is because
of how gigantic these outlets have
become if you have more local politics
being discussed by people and folks on
the ground who live in the communities
that they're discussing about cover the
issues i think you get more reliable
information but when you have cnn trying
to report on everything that happens in
the country it's just all the
information is ripe to be manipulated by
them well and you've also got what four
major companies that control all the
media outlets so there's
there's a monopoly on it and they're all
kind of slanted the same way and they're
all money driven so
once you're money driven the truth's out
the window it's going to make me the
most money today yeah absolutely i feel
really bad about this because i'm
blanking on his name we had him on very
great guest he talked about the loudoun
county
um assault case
he he was the journalist who exposed it
oh luke rosie yes okay thank you one
thing he said that i thought was really
instructive was
he
as a local decided that he was just
going to pay attention to an issue which
was near to him and so he called the
father who was being maligned in the
media and asked him why he responded the
way he did and the father
explained that his daughter was sexually
assaulted that's the kind of journalism
we need but it's no coincidence that it
was a person who was a member of that
community who actually got that
information
it's getting to the point where i don't
i i don't think i can trust media
sources
that were not there on the scene or
aren't part of the community because
they have and also they have no
incentive not to lie about what happened
there it's not their community well take
a look at this right so we have the
story times of israel says ukraine could
declare neutrality offer security
guarantees to russia and potentially
accept a compromise in the contested
area in the country's east to secure
peace without delay
hinting at possible concessions uh
yo this this sounds basically like
defeat
like russia's one
the president of ukraine says says we're
going to give you what you want
now they've been reporting over and over
again that russia was losing they showed
these videos over and over again of
russian tanks being hit and russians
being ambushed they lie about you know
these tanks running people over
all just insane propaganda i i you know
i i'd ask people do you think vladimir
putin is intentionally targeting
civilians and they would say yes and i'm
saying why would you think that like i
don't think putin's a good guy but we're
not like human beings are not comic book
villains well he's not dumb he knows if
he does that then they go in and take
over ukraine and they occupy it he's not
going to have their loyalty but by their
family members i should clarify too what
i mean is
there are people who believe that
vladimir putin is killing civilians for
the sake of killing civilians right he
is
his his invasion is killing civilians in
the name of his military objectives but
i'm specific what i specifically mean is
like do you think he was like hey go in
there and kill civilians well of course
not he's saying go in there and just do
what you have to do regardless of the
concept no i mean when when our
government kills civilians it's
collateral damage and that's just the
cost of waging war but of course
whenever when other governments do it
it's because they intentionally want to
kill innocent people yes but i do have
to pause there uh and give issue a
slight correction
under the obama administration we did
something a bit more clever
when when the united states killed
civilians in the middle east we just
said are they adult men and they're
enemy combatants if they were if they
were combat aged males
military agent men they would not be
classified as civilian deaths that
slipped past me i didn't know that let's
talk about it's horrible dirty dirty
stuff and that's what's fascinating is
that
whether it was trump or just this
emergent phenomenon you end up with a
lot of regular americans
uh populist conservative types
just finally coming out and being like
hey we we don't want any of that
we don't we don't we don't want military
age males just being bombed and then you
guys just pass the buck donald trump
runs as a republican saying bring our
troops back the war makes no sense and
people are clapping and cheering for him
joe biden
you know i love how the democrats can
keep pushing these lies about we don't
want war and then what do you get you
get chaos you get more war
isn't it so crazy under donald trump no
new wars
certainly wars were being were still
being fought yeah he was far from
perfect on foreign policy joe biden gets
in
how long until we got a new war yeah
well to be fair russia's invasion of
ukraine is different from a u.s invasion
somewhere yeah but there's there's
global instability we've got reports of
troop u.s troop movements in syria this
is almost immediately so it's not
surprising korea's shooting there
or china which everyone's shooting the
missiles back in the south korea yeah
north korea yeah i mean look under under
donald trump we had we had security
issues we had we had concerns you had
north korea doing their nuclear tests
but i think the reason vladimir putin
didn't invade ukraine is because donald
trump crushed isis
and then pulled our troops out and
russia was like all right and russia
went over there and got their tail
kicked down
yeah in the middle east i mean they
didn't fare very well when they went
over there they thought they were going
to go over and just do what they do and
they didn't and you talked about the
propaganda
zielinski was it yesterday or the day
before so i think it was yesterday said
they're going to start having back
putting kids back in school
yeah wow and i thought
now is are they really going to go back
to school or is he going to say they are
and then blow up one of his own skulls
with nobody in it and say we had these
casualties to make it look like rush is
this super enemy again
i don't know i just i'd like to i want
to see in the next week or two if one of
their schools happens to get bombed and
then you'll know
it's it kind of laid the ground for this
the the challenge with false flags is
that
it's always a simpler solution that an
enemy bombed their enemy
but we do know that
countries and governments use false flex
like the us and the gulf of tonkin or
the proposals around operation northwest
that's right yeah so
it's tough zolensky's lied already
several times when he was like oh no
they're bombing the nuclear facility
quick nato no fly zone and then they're
like there's radiation oh and then you
know the international times the picture
with his generals it was like four three
years ago was it really yeah it was like
2018. there's a video that uh
this is the remarkable thing people are
like
it looks like a green screen
and then you actually see people online
it's not a green screen it's just it's
just because they front like they do a
bunch of lighting so it makes it look
like like the back isn't uh you know
properly connected you can see his
shadow and i'm like
the image behind him is a still image
the trees aren't moving there's no
movement no wind nothing you trees move
yeah
and it's just
whatever man i don't know i just what i
do know is they lie everybody lies no
yeah absolutely and it's so bizarre how
people are willing to be completely
cynical about their own political
leaders until
warfare breaks out and then every single
thing they say is gospel truth and if
you if you doubt what they're telling
you you're siding with the enemy it's
ridiculous yeah now you're they don't
become good people put an apologist yeah
no i'm not i'm just calling both sides
they're both dirty exactly like the
people who have consistently lied to us
for their entire time on the public
stage didn't miraculously become honest
human beings because a conflict broke
out on the international stage thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you